house gum resumes Baird welcome back to
another episode of the walking dead
season 2 finale it's gonna be a good one
let's continue playing here's a fire
point this is cries we have to get a
warm she's gotta breathe sit up
it's just gone looks [ __ ] gone
we should have gone around goddamn it
we should have just been gone I tried to
help him I just was that I started
try
Hey
you son of a [ __ ] this is your [ __ ]
fault Kenny don't matter what it's
nobody's damn fault
I'm freezing we just get a fire started
look at this place
just a stack of [ __ ] toothpicks bet
those magical supplies are [ __ ] -
what no speaking English [ __ ] you
[ __ ] call me pieces get any food
stupid
just stop
what did you do to him
there's another just like it he wasn't
lying
you want to tell me how a can of [ __ ]
chili it's gonna help who is beating a
kid to death gonna help anyone this is
your fault and you damn well know it
I'm tying him up fine Mike
help me get a fire started you okay he's
hurt real bad Mike
yeah yeah okay
everything is so [ __ ] right now
everything your life
I thought I had matches
well that was easy
I don't know bye so awkward but I think
she should take her clothes off if
they're way
he really hates us
let me take a look at you kid
Jesus he could have killed you
the [ __ ] is wrong with him you're up
how's the chili it's a spy fries out
back trying to get some stupid truck
started here you should eat something
you okay thank you
I shipped them so much
I can't believe he's gone I lost people
before but it just hasn't felt this this
shitty in a while he cared about you too
Jane I know he did
goddamnit
I shouldn't have come back
I knew this would happen I knew it well
I'm glad you did I'm gonna find
something to clean that up thank you
thank you
I can't take this [ __ ] anymore
can anyone feeling better yeah
hell of a day but we gotta get movin if
you feel it up to it I could use a hand
out back with this truck really house
ain't worth the crap but the vehicles
ain't in bad shape
really now look Clem I know we're all
art but I need your help here okay I'll
wait for you out back nice crib the fine
I surprised that baby isn't crying like
constantly attracting zambese or
whatever this is so I'm like thought it
would be like a dainty alarm mm or some
[ __ ] like that Clem yeah just be careful
wow it was am claimed a clue
what are we gonna do here exactly what
did she have to say
I know she was running her mouth what
did she say you shouldn't have done that
to arvo
I know I know clam butt but now you
don't care you can't do that
Jesus Clem you know me you know I'm not
like that
you scared me you scared all of us Kenny
it won't happen again that's a promise
I hope so what happened it's over but AJ
needs us now we got to stick together on
this thing all right
right come on let's see if the trucks
gonna go it's too cold it's not gonna
work my daddy always had a half dozen
wrecks he was fixing up he was a mean
sumbitch but he taught me respect girl
like Jane could learn a thing or two
about that oh I like her just give her
some time maybe you're right hell I
didn't know what to make him leave first
of course he helped me in mine more
times than I can remember Jane helped us
back on the road all right
give it a turn
let's go to make it go yeah
oh god that thing happened again where
the arrow goes outside the screen I'm
with the [ __ ] there we go
nothing we're so close Clem not really a
little bit of luck I can get this thing
running and then we can get out on the
road and really make some distance
Wellington's gotta be out there
those rumors can't all be bunk I mean
he'll there's got to mix the guys in me
he'll other than snow and goddamn
Eurotrash sounds good to me
we're gonna make it glamour I know it
all right turn it again did you turn it
yeah god damn it
Kenny are you okay we gotta get movin if
we're gonna keep AJ alive we're running
out of time I gotta get this thing to
start gonna try warming up the battery
go on inside I don't like leaving it
with that girl
creepy angle Jesus let's talk to him a
little bit more need me help
I'm fine go check on AJ well I didn't
really work it's a dame party girl
Clemmy clue excavator that sounds
amazing we should ride that to victory I
stay to finish this place
god damn she walk slow come on Bonnie
want one
no thanks
easy choice do you remember when you saw
me first back at the lodge check her for
weapons I liked you from the start you
ever done something you regret even if
it's something you knew you had to do oh
I wish I hadn't done that to Sarita no
you had to try you know I'll say one
thing about Luke no matter where you end
up there's always one bad seed rocking
the boat but I don't think he would have
ever been that guy yeah he was always
good let me ask you something Clem
when's the last time anyone did what you
wanted
what do you mean I think people respect
me really I think so well good for you
honey
you know I've been all over run with a
lot of people a lot of men and listened
to a lot of promises ain't one of them
come true I'm starting to think there
might be another way
you know what what are you talking about
Danny wait what is this way you're
talking about I'm gonna go take a piss
well that's just nice don't let the same
you bite how's it how's that good for
let's go back to the baby
and let's talk to Elmen no not a lien I
mean the Russian boy
guess we can't Hey
I can arvo wouldn't shut up so I moved
him in here god dammit seen that look
before
Marva that's name-o
he'll be fine Clem he beat that boy
within an inch of his life we are way
past fine
I know Kenny's a nice guy Clem
I bet Carver was a nice guy too once
probably had a nice job a nice pretty
wife then all this happened one day he
caved some kids face in realized he
could sleep at night
Kenny isn't carver he just made a
mistake all I'm saying is start thinking
about what happens if you're wrong I
have faith in Kenny YouTube's known each
other a long time
sooner or later you're gonna have to
decide how much that's worth I think it
needs food it
Clemmy we're working that magic I guess
we're getting close
that's what worries me
she knows this whole thing is not gonna
work out there's not much left I was
running with some people a long time ago
down near DC some guy got trapped middle
of a crosswalk can't remember his name
he has to call me Mary Jane he was a
douche bag
anyway the dick got stuck under a car
hiding from a dozen walkers one after
another they went down there trying to
save him lost four people before we got
him out
and they had to try right yeah didn't
find out till later he was already bit
turn and rip the neck right out of this
old lady the look on her face was she
was just staring up at the sky like she
was watching a bird look lemon
Oh
he got it working
I shouldn't even care to finish works
what'd I tell you
so what's the plan how much food do we
have at least a week and for the baby we
need to find a place for the baby yeah
someplace warm I agree we should head
back south what we're kind of freeze to
death I don't know whose stupid idea was
to march up here in the first place but
is it that she's right what if we went
back to house wait what
[ __ ] that I was thinking more like Texas
Texas the [ __ ] it was just an idea we
already talked about this I'm sorry we
they were going to find Wellington right
Clemmie Wellington tinnie it's freezing
up here man
it's only gonna get worse we came this
far we're not going back
don't have to leave right now
I don't know what to choose inhibit we
don't have time says you look I don't
give two shits about what you people
think I got this truck working so I say
where we go and we're headed [ __ ]
north it's the best chance we got to
help an agent what about our beau who Oh
the [ __ ] yeah he ain't coming with us
you're just gonna leave him here I don't
give a good goddamn where he goes he's
done we should ask him what he wants
yeah there's a concept
he knows the area he can help us oh yes
um help he's been he got Luke you it
wasn't his fault
but maybe if you eased up on him before
he wouldn't have run away in the first
place good thing about that Kenny either
way I'm not going anywhere in the middle
of the night yeah me neither
it could be a hurt out there you want
that child's blood on your hands Mike
we're all gonna die out here if you
don't calm the [ __ ] down
Kenny haven't we been through enough for
one day jesus [ __ ] christ remember
the last time we had a working car and
sat around on our asses Clem I'm going
inside
god damn it
can't just walk away from us why did you
have to make a big deal out of that I
don't understand they're not gonna go
now you better talk some sense in him
for his sake I mean they all walk north
for a reason in the comic book the the
zambese freeze and they get really slow
and they get stuck in there in the
ground kinda so they're really weakened
here get the [ __ ] out of here
it's me clam sorry just give me a second
Oh God close the door
can you believe this clam I bring him a
working truck and they act like I just
[ __ ] in their cereal I have to agree and
they did have a stick up her ass but I
thought at least my kid had more sense
well why can't we just leave tomorrow
yeah look we got maybe a day's worth of
food for that kid left that's it clam
think about Rebecca and Alvin I mean
what if Lee hadn't gone tearing across
half of Georgia looking for you a lot of
folks died to make that happen
a lot of folks died to get us this far
we owe it to them to see this done this
is different yeah where are we gonna
find baby formula
I don't know but sitting around here
ain't away I wish Lee was here
would you think he'd say probably knock
some sense into you
I think he'd tell me to try to keep the
group together we can't just give up on
this kid I mean what's the point of
going on after that that's what people
likely knew and when people like Jane
won't ever understand
look I know Willington might be [ __ ]
but where there's smoke there's fire
krysta heard about it too right you know
when I first saw you back at that Lodge
thought I was dreaming
and when you sat with those people at
dinner
well I knew you were growing up and yeah
I felt sad but also pride pride I hadn't
felt in a long time really but I need
you now Clem there have to be folks
doing better than us it's the only
chance that child has yeah but we can't
do it alone we need the others that's
why I got to be able to count on you
clam
we gotta convince him you and me
look we'll figure everything out in the
morning come on let's get some sleep so
we got to be ready I'd rather sleep in
the car should be honest that house is
this [ __ ] anyway like what the hell oh
you see oh boy what's gonna happen I
have no idea
someone's fapping yep definitely it
oh that's what that was I was like what
the hell is that actually I still don't
know what the hell that is
Oh Oh L guys ready
okay I'm gonna not pull a gun on them
I'll do it if I need to
oh there it is
[ __ ] you easy easy now step back Clem
[ __ ]
what are you doing I got the rest of it
hmm
you [ __ ] we aah don't keep it
down all right
nobody else has to get involved they
just leave the baby what the [ __ ] okay
who Kenny
damage it we don't have time just just
be quiet clamp please we are quiet we're
just talking
all right
they just gonna leave us like I I feel
so betrayed no you're not [ __ ] gonna
do why are you doing this they didn't
give us any choice yeah they [ __ ] did
smooch oolitic why are they siding with
him I'm sorry why don't you let me know
buddy just give me the gun come back to
[ __ ] off I'm not gonna hurt you
I'll shoot
here we go
yeah we know why it's fine just
sorry I didn't mean for this to come on
time
muchachos hit spills from the future
here to ruin your life yeah right lease
your 25 minutes we have to end this
episode here as always but next one is
the last one you don't want to miss it
it's gonna be amazing amazing say it
with me amazing so thank you for liking
this video and I'll see you tomorrow as
always stay awesome